le président patriat vous m'interrogez
sur un point d'étape ou en réalité sur
le sur le confinement
d'abord un mot pour dire que la mesure
de confinement qui a été décidé a été
décidée en fonction d'une stratégie qui
consistait à faire en sorte que le
nombre de cas sévères de malades
lesquels justifie une hospitalisation et
parfois une admission au service de
réanimation ne dépasse pas la capacité
d'accueil des services de réanimation
français c'était l'objectif du
confinement pour faire face au nombre de
camarades nous avons le bon nombre de
cas sévères nous avons considérablement
augmenter notre capacité d'accueil dans
les services de réanimation
je le dis parce que c'est un c'est en
vérité un succès à bas bruit la capacité
qu'a eue le système hospitalier le
système de soins français à passer d'une
capacité normale de 5000 lits de
réanimation à plus de 10 millions
aujourd'hui et à pouvoir continuer à
accueillir dans des conditions de
tension considérable
un nombre de malades en situation très
grave
pendant souvent une très longue période
est exceptionnel la mobilisation du
système de soins évidemment l'engagement
des personnels soignants
il faut le souligner le répéter le
mettre en évidence mais au delà des
personnels soignants tout ce qui
concourt à l'offre de soins les
personnels administratifs dans les ars
ont fait un travail remarquable pour
permettre justement cette montée en
puissance des capacités de réanimation
et ceux qui ont organisé les évacuations
sanitaires auxquels nous avons procédé
soit entre régions soit vers l'étranger
ont aussi réalisé un exploit logistique
jamais jamais réalisée en france
dans cette nature mais jamais même
imaginer dans ces proportions et c'est
un grand succès du système hospitalier
qu'il faut saluer à sa juste mesure
nous sommes au moment où nous parlons à
un moment de l'épidémie où le nombre
d'augmentations le nombre d'admissions
en service de réanimation donc l'
indicateur essentiel que nous suivons à
ce stade est en ralentissement
il progresse encore
mais avec un une progression qui est
désormais très lente très lente
nous avons dépassé les 7000 cas en
réanimation malades du code vide plus de
7000 cas c'est du jamais vu
j'avais eu sept mille personnes en
service de réanimation à cause de la
même maladie en france et nous avons
jusqu'à présent réussi à pouvoir
accueillir dans les services de
réanimation suffisamment de malades
tous les malades ont cassé vers
l'élément qui laisse entrevoir peut-être
et vous remarquez que je suis prudent
monsieur président quatrième peut-être
un peu d'espoir c'est que cette
progression se ralentit au point que
peut-être nous arrivons à quelque chose
qui ressemblerait un plateau encore je
dis les choses prudemment quelque chose
qui ressemblerait un plateau c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
si ça se confirme et c'est très
probablement très certainement là
l'effet du confinement de ce point de
vue cette évolution
ce ralentissement de la courbe des
admissions réanimation vient confirmer
la nécessité du confinement
c'est ce que l'on peut faire et ce dont
on peut faire état s'agissant du bilan
sanitaire ce qui m'incite évidemment et
ce qu'ils m'invitent évidemment à dire
que on peut faire un point d'étape mais
on ne peut pas faire le bilan définitif
du continent car le confinement est
appelée à durer si il ne durait pas ou
s'ils n'étaient pas respectées nous
prendrions le risque qui en vérité ne
serait pas un risque qui serait une
certitude de voir le virus circule est à
nouveau très vite et donc le nombre de
cas a admis en réanimation augmenté
alors même que le tissu hospitalier a
été sur sollicité et qui se trouve dans
un état de stress de fatigue qu'il faut
évidemment bien avoir en tête c'est la
raison pour laquelle je dis
régulièrement que leur dû des
confinement n'est pas venue toute notre
énergie doit être consacré à faire en
sorte que le confinement soit respecté
pour que les effets positifs de ce
confinement puisse se confirmer dans le
nombre de cas sévères admis en
réanimation
j'espère que je suis claire en disant
des choses ainsi c'est le premier
élément de bilan que je peux donner à
votre appréciation en ajoutant qu' un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes qui étaient
les nôtres notamment sur la capacité à
fournir des médicaments
compte tenu de l'augmentation incroyable
de l'utilisation de ces médicaments en
france et partout dans le monde
au même moment et un rythme
incroyablement intense que nous savons
faire face nous savons faire face à ce
risque est que je m'en félicite
le confinement il a donc un effet
sanitaire positif s'agissant du coc vite
il a un effet sanitaire qu'il ne faut
pas négliger et qui peut être négatif
c'est évidemment le moindre recours aux
soins de tous ceux qui malades ou étant
susceptible de tomber malades ont moins
recours à l'offre de soin parce qu'il
leur est difficile d'aller chez le
médecin parce qu'il leur est difficile
de trouver le spécialiste qui parfois à
fermer son activité ça peut arriver j'ai
des exemples assez précis en tête
dans une ville qui m'est cher et donc
nous savons que le confinement un impact
sanitaire qui peut être négatif vers
d'autres que ceux qui seraient
susceptibles de pouvoir être admis en
réanimation à l'hôpital et je
l'indiquent parce que le ministre hier à
l'occasion de sa prise de parole a été
très clair sur l'enjeu sanitaire qui
s'attache à pouvoir ne pas allier à
faire en sorte que les soins continuent
à être prodigué les soins de ville et
continuer à être prodigués les examens
continue de prodiguer alors même qu'on
est dans une perte de confinement c'est
évidemment un objectif sanitaire
essentiel c'est le deuxième point que je
veux souligner s'agissant du bilan du
confinement un troisième point
évidemment c'est l'impact économique il
est massif
il est très négatif il est brutale et il
va susciter en france comme partout dans
le monde les impacts nationaux se
répondant et amplifiant encore la donne
il va se traduire par un choc économique
que chacun imagine mais dont personne ne
sait encore la totalité de l'impact
le bilan que je peux faire des mesures
qui ont été prises
j'en arrêterait à ce stade c'est que le
dispositif que vous avez adopté de
chômage partiel et que nous avons
proposée est très fortement sollicités
ce sont aujourd'hui près de 6 millions
de salariés qui sont couverts par le
chômage partiel
c'est absolument considérable et bien
entendu cela a un coût collectif
absolument considérable les reports de
charges fiscales et sociales ont permis
de soulager de près de 7 milliards
d'euros la trésorerie des entreprises
pour le seul mois de mars c'est là aussi
évidemment quelque chose d'important
le fonds de solidarité qui étaient
installés et qui est financé par l'état
par les assureurs et par les régions les
taillant verser 750 millions les
assureurs ayant verte et centre des
premiers millions qu'ils ont versé
premiers 200 millions et les régions
versant bientôt je le crois leur
contribution ce fonds de solidarité a
répandu a reçu près de 700000 demande
alors qu'il a été créé au début de la
semaine 700 milles demandé à distribuer
ou est sur le point de distribuer 700
millions d'euros aux tpe les plus
durement frappés par la crise enfin le
prêt garanti par l'état se déploie
rapidement avec des pré accord de
financement qui porte sur plus de 13
milliards au jour où à l'heure où je
vous parle plus de 13 milliards donc la
réponse est passive mais ne nous voilons
pas la face l'impact sera considérable
il est encore beaucoup trop tôt pour
l'apprécier puisqu'il sera très
directement liée à la durée de
confinement est que cette durée de
confinement est appelée aujourd'hui
de toute évidence a duré quelques temps
encore on aura l'occasion de revenir sur
ce point je crois
voilà ce que je pouvais dire au sénat
sur la question vous me posez monsieur
le président merci